the unexpected deaths are always a bit
more difficult for me the hardest thing
is its covering them with the shroud did
I put them away yeah last moments of
life I think is quite special how did
you get into nursing I was never going
to be a nurse never but I got a holiday
job at the local hospital and I got
quite taken by I trained King's College
Hospital in South London where I'm
working now that's a nice same uni I was
like why I sort of fell into it I was a
medic convert and basically fell in love
with nursing and wanted that kind of
patient contact answer more than the
medical side of things yeah you're right
I think it was the people contact
especially if you see somebody get
better or even if you're able to help
look after them not get better it's a
fantastic privilege really yeah on my
very first ward in fact I nursed a
nine-year-old who had her leg amputated
in fact full amputation at the hip for
cancer and then when she got really sick
they said I was the person she felt safe
when I was around so I went quite often
in my off duty until she died and fact
that she was nine it was just that was
really really hardening I had a card
from her mother just this week
her mother's just over a hundred so it's
an amazing contact I don't think there's
any other patient at that level of
contact playing is nice that you can
keep that kind of relationship with yeah
someone like and just after all this
time
do you take your work home with you yes
yeah I try not to I think I think I have
left it at the door and any work but I
think about things sometimes it makes me
appreciate my family a lot more thing
when I've had something similar happen
at work I mean it's difficult to date
within work because it's such a high
pressured environment and it being shift
work you know strokes be on the same
shift but I think it's also difficult to
date outside of work because people
don't understand thirteen hours four or
five times a week is it adds up a bit
I remember up my my leaving party my
partner going round he's quite he's not
normally very extrovert and I remember
his game and saying to people I know
you're sorry she's leaving but I'm
getting her back I don't think it ever
occur to me quite what an impact on in
that that job had had and I think it's
that I think it's a big issue for room
for nurses that probably doesn't get
talked about enough and one thing good
things about this somewhat monastic life
we had one we had to live in the nurses
home and be home at 12 and so on it was
a sense in which we we had a lot of
almost and Co counseling we wouldn't
have called it that I can remember the
first person who saw her death and we
all sat round and gave her coffee and
asked her what it was like and and then
when something went wrong there was this
natural group to share experiences which
it's very hard to recreate I think in
the current sort of shift systems yes I
mean we don't even get time to really
debrief after a an instant-on shift I
mean we're almost so oblivious to it
because it's our way of life and I think
you know people are either very vocal
and they leave or they aren't vocal and
accept it but I suppose like you've
found you realize once you leave it how
much you missed what are the
difficulties in the doctor nurse
relationship sometimes I think it's a
very male/female relationship even when
that they aren't necessarily the genders
my perception before I had any sort of
insight into it was very much based on
what I've seen on TV you are the doctors
aide and you do this to help them and
you do that to help them there's nothing
like nurses often know far better than
the doctor concerned and yet the
authority lies there it's still very
difficult I mean we've had first year of
medical school and they struggling to
prescribe paracetamol for them it was
such a big thing and for us we're kind
of a bit like you're supposed to be the
doctor you're supposed to be the person
that we go to for things but I always
think that puts us down because yeah
Nursing has so much knowledge absolutely
and so much skill that yeah I I remember
once a patient need had a couple of
cardiac arrests and he stripped the
doctors hand and said thank you doctor
for saving my life and then he turned to
me and said thank you sister a telling
doctor to get a move on to save my life
we're always taught that patients here
is the last thing that goes and I can
remember who this doctor was standing
nervously with the rib relation to get
the move on he's fading or he's gone or
something and he'd obviously heard that
I think it's nice when you get the
appreciation one of my most moving sort
piece of appreciation from sort of
family was a teenager who'd lost her
newborn baby
it's unfortunate tried to end her life
but she'd done it in such a way that
meant that she wasn't able to go to her
baby's funeral she was too unwell to
actually like leave bed effectively but
we could have a viewing and spend time
with her baby and she was so grateful
for that she had like a new lease on
life after yeah she actively wanted to
engage and rehab and then get out and
sort of carry on with her life it kind
of reinstalled in me the fact that I
knew that this is what I wanted to do
that's great when
given the pressures and the bureaucracy
it is possible still occasionally to
make that space to do something extra
special
how do you feel when a patient dies the
unexpected deaths are always a bit more
difficult and the deaths of people that
don't have anyone so they might be the
last of their family or the family or
abroad and things I think I feel those
sort of data more provided I've been
with someone as they've died I'd
normally feel quite not satisfied but
relieved for me one of my first shifts
in charge someone that was in their late
90s and we just watched him get steadily
more and well for three days and then
his family coming in Ozzy because I was
in charge sitting down with the doctor
at home to describe what happened and
they didn't want to come in say collect
his belongings so obviously me and the
actual nurses caring for him on that
shift went in and so I packed up his
cards and his photos and you know as
photos if you like him and his wife from
when they were younger and things of
that and sort of putting them in a bag
and closing that back was difficult
sometimes a thing it was hard not to
feel that you felt most people don't
need to think about death and it makes
you think about your own and your family
and loved ones but also that person was
being born or dying you're very
vulnerable and dependent and it's such a
privilege to be able to help that moment
be as good as possible yeah and even
afterwards I think people anywhere that
I talk to people that have died for me
the hardest thing is is covering them
with the shroud and taping and like it's
where did I put them away yes here right
roughing tape around it ahead is strange
last moments of life I think yeah being
with Sonja's right
special solutely do you think nursing is
still seen as a feminine profession yeah
I think it's it's come a long way but my
granddad was very much against it as it
was for him it was that feminine
profession that has no progression and
sort of no ceiling the people call him
the male nurse
yes I was think that's terrible praise
knows how to gender I'm wonderful it's
not surprising niceness it's all women I
think the numbers are something like
nine or ten percent and it hasn't budged
no I think I just hit 10% yeah very very
rare in my training days I think there
was only one and he worked in the VD
clinic which was in the basement people
don't talk about it very much but a very
significant number of the best of the
chief executives in the NHS our nurses
by background what is the greatest
threat to Nursing as a profession I've
gone into nursing because I want to
nurse and I want to provide care and I
want to do best by my patients it's the
expectation that we're supposed to cover
it's five or six different job roles and
there's a risk of the profession getting
lost as to what Nursing is and I can't
do it when the bureaucracy in the red
tape stopped me giving my best care I
think the bureaucracy is probably one of
the things that's changed a lot since
since I was actively nursing shortage
has put the discussion about nurses are
on the agenda than it's been for several
years and again again people seem to
default they talk about the health
service and they talk about beds and
doctors often and yet you say when I was
at the LCN there are lots of beds in
John Lewis across the road beds means
nurses to look after the area yeah I
have been a patient recently and I've
been overwhelmed with how good it is and
yet if I look at the papers the NHS is
in absolute crisis and in decline in a
terrible state
I do think how press like bad news
stories anyway but I do think the most
nurses hide here oh and talk to
do feel that they're under much more
pressure than they were a few years ago
I personally am a bit worried about the
state of the NHS I think we've become
quite good at papering over the cracks
so the issues perhaps on tell with we're
not compromising on safety but it's
because we're working at 110% I say a
lot but I think it takes someone to die
before anyone actually makes any changes
or actually takes any interest in what
people have been saying for months
sometimes years I think it takes a lot
of someone to maybe see some things
we've seen I'll do what you do and you
have to be persistent why is something
about nursing that would surprise the
general public how much fun it is I
think sometimes people talk about it
being you know oh I couldn't I can be a
nurse you're wonderful to be a nurse
suppose actually it's it's not all doom
and gloom and some of it's great fun
what would you say to someone who's just
starting their career you've chosen a
fantastic job not many people have the
opportunity to make such a difference
it's not an easy job or knees the life
but never doubt that you're doing a
really really good job like you as one
person can change hundreds of people's
life so just enjoy it a lot feels very
similar to it yeah maybe maybe that's
good maybe it's the facilities are still
the same but it's been but a lot
progression so it's been really good
talking to thank you I don't really
think I knew what was happening to start
with when we hit the I Edie it went off
and I just remember skies and skies and
and thinking oh crap am i dead am i
dying like not knowing like that I think
in that instant that yeah I think
definitely was my most afraid